that really is amazing though to think
that with all those questions red flags
concerns you're right will fuller ends
up with more money than juju smith
schuster but that's what having the
ability to stretch it is defense
brings big plays uh
and that's why desean jackson is finding
another home despite all these years in
the nfl this will be season number 14.
he's 34 years old
but he's got a one-year deal to go back
home
to southern california he's been playing
on the east coast his entire nfl career
he played college football cal berkeley
and now the rams announced last night
desean jackson bringing that element
to la for a year you got robert woods
you got cooper cup everything's taken
care of underneath now you got that guy
who if healthy can stretch the field and
give matthew stafford a long down the
field target the problem is
guys played eight games over the last
two years yeah that that's the big thing
i mean it's like fuller you know that
receivers like this you know to always
make the comparison you know they're
they're cheetahs right they're they're
cheetahs and the fact that they're high
octane big speed you know but if they
pull the slightest muscle it's like whoa
okay you know we we can't get out there
and chase gazelles today i mean that
that's that's how this is like special
special specimens and desean jackson and
yeah he's been backed up but man if he's
healthy
holy crapola would that be fun to watch
out there with the rams you know first
off he's got to be so happy to go back
to california i've been around desean a
little bit and i think that's always
been on his radar but
to go there
and you mentioned it with cooper cup and
woods who could do all you know a little
bit like we just talked about with with
will fuller they could do all the 15 to
20 to 25 and the five yards and all that
type of stuff but now you got matt
stafford coming out on the edge and it's
you know a little play action bootleg
fake to the right and now he's rolling
to the left and he's got woods in the
flat and cooper cup coming over the
middle and usually they run like the
outside guy like a desean jackson on the
20-yard comeback oh now they're going to
have him fake the 20-yard comeback go 60
yards down the field fake the 20-yard
comeback posted over the middle 50 yards
down the field and they got a
quarterback who's got a flamethrower for
an arm
and that's going to work you talk about
them being able to stretch the whole
field and make you defend the whole
field that way that's where they can be
scary with stafford desean jackson those
receivers you mentioned and we know
mcveigh's going to run the ball i mean
it makes sense if to stay healthy right
if healthy and really the three games he
played in 2019 the last
like it was week one he was spectacular
two long touchdown passes as the eagles
erased a 17-0 deficit against washington
right week two it was in atlanta monday
night game i believe barely played
sunday night game barely played right
that's when he started to have something
groin hernia something like that then
came back late in the year for just
later in the year for just like a quick
little nah i'm and so it was one game
that year it was great but it was one
game and that one game can make a
difference for a team but i i just i i
it'll be interesting to see
how much yeah the fact that it's been
about 12 hours and i don't think we've
seen how much tells me not much at this
point because he's gonna have to prove
himself and at a minimum i would want to
put a lot of incentives in there and per
game roster bonuses
where i don't pay him unless he's
actually able to suit up and play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports